dans les pyrénées c'est un village où
les hommes parler d'autres fois comme
les oiseaux as dans la vallée d'ossau
cette langue un cas unique en europe
étaient déjà en voie de disparition dans
les années 70 il s'agissait en fait du
patois béarnais adapté en sifflement en
particulier pratiqué par les bergers
l'origine de cette pratique reste un
mystère
son existence a été révélée en 1959 par
un spécialiste le professeur rené guy
bus n'est pas ou pas il a alors invité
deux bergers à paris afin d'étudier
cette langue sifflé la décortiquer
l'enregistrer la langue sifflet
permettait aux bergers de communiquer
d'une vallée à l'autre de façon très
nette à des kilomètres alors que la voix
ne deviendrai qu'un écho à l'origine
c'était une langue utilitaires
elle servait à lancer l' alerte en cas
de guerre ou de danger à signaler la
mort d'un proche
mais peu à peu la langue sifflet s'est
éteinte
c'est tout à fait normal puis violent
une utilité à disparaissent lorsqu'elle
est remplacé par quelque chose de
perfectionner téléphone qui voile qui le
théâtre 4 enfin des des infrastructures
routières beaucoup plus j'ai évolué les
derniers locuteurs ont disparu en 2002
pour autant la langue sifflet fait
partie du patrimoine berner ces
dernières années elle est à nouveau
enseigner comme dans cette école de
savane est d'origine en 2007 la langue
sifflet retrouve non seulement une vie
mais aussi une utilité bien différente
de celle des anciens les stratégies de
rugby sifflé sur le terrain c'est avec
malice que la nouvelle génération s'est
approprié l'héritage linguistique des
ayew
[Musique]